we've talked a lot about the i guess i
would call it the need to create
uh fake scandals and crises kind of out
of thin air
in these early months of the joe biden
administration and part of that is
necessitated by the fact that while joe
biden
hasn't done everything i wish he would
he had done and he hasn't done
everything perfectly and
etc etc all the normal disclaimers he's
had
nothing even close to a major scandal
and for a while and we'll get to this in
the
in the voicemail segment um for a while
the focus was on the so-called crisis at
the border which
was not a crisis under donald trump
according to these very same
people um even though nothing really
materially
changed from trump to biden i wouldn't
say they've moved on from that but
now the slightly more conspiratorial
enclaves of the right are going into why
won't joe biden
let us investigate whether kovid was
man-made that's the gist of this and fox
news reporter peter ducey
has gone from asking different faux
gotcha questions from one press briefing
to the next
to just repeating the exact same
conspiratorial fo gotcha questions day
after day so check this out
monday tuesday two press briefings exact
same question back to back
monday is the first one peter ducey
asked joe biden's white house press
secretary jen
saki about an investigation into whether
covid19 was man-made now remember
i have no problem investigating that dr
fauci said he has no problem
investigating it
it's just that right now there's no
evidence
that covid was man-made but do the
investigation
do everything you need to in terms of
covid19
so this is monday here is a peter ducey
asking shouldn't we be investigating
this new investigation
but with 589 920 dead
americans at what point does president
biden say
we don't want to wait for the w.h.o we
don't know what they're doing this needs
to be an american-led
effort to get to the bottom of what
happened well first of all we need
access to the underlying data and
information in order to have that
investigation and
but he talks all the time about how he's
known president xi
for a long time so why can't you just
and we need them
for that information i think you're
misunderstanding how this process
actually works
an international investigation led by
the world health organization
is something that we've actually been
pressing for for several months
in coordination with a range of partners
around the world
we need that data we need that
information from the chinese government
what we can't do
and what i would caution anyone doing is
leaping ahead of an actual
international process we don't have
enough data and information to jump to a
conclusion at this point
in time so is there any amount of
the casualties from koben in this
country that would make you want to
not wait for an international effort and
just do it
as well i i have to say i think the
family members of the
loved ones whose lives have been lost
and deserve
accurate information data not the
jumping to a conclusion
without having the information necessary
to conclude what the origins are
what we do share everyone in this
country has a desire to know
how this started where it started and
prevent it from ever happening again
that's something we all share go ahead
okay so that was monday and jen
saki says yeah do the probe do it let's
find out
peter ducey wants to frame it and so
many of these right wingers
you know when they seize on a kernel of
something then they just try to blow it
up into
i don't know popcorn he wants to frame
it as
at what point would covet be serious
enough for joe biden to want to
investigate the origins
of the virus and that's of course not
the issue it's already serious enough
it was trump and republicans who
downplayed the seriousness all along
nobody's trying to block an
investigation into the origins it's just
without evidence right now the assertion
that kovid was
likely or probably man-made is an
assertion without evidence and so we
can't do that at this point in time it
doesn't seem that he gets it
so cut to the next day yesterday tuesday
peter ducey
with the same thing again and jen saki
actually points out peter didn't we do
this yesterday
all right i guess we're doing it again
does president biden think these
theories we hear more about now that
kova 19 may have been man-made and
escaped from a lab in china
are a wacky conspiracy theory or based
on what he has
heard and been briefed on does he think
that's possible well we went through
this journey
together yesterday so let's do it again
uh so the president believes there needs
to be an independent investigation
one that's run by the international
community it's an international pandemic
that has killed hundreds of thousands of
people around the world he believes the
chinese need to do more to put forward
data to be more transparent and in the
second phase of this
effort he's certainly hopeful that will
be the case and he believes that every
theory should be explored through that
process but that we shouldn't jump to
conclusions before
that data and that information is made
available this is
straight up kowtowing to the fox news
audience the fox news audience
loves conspiracies they love the idea
that democrats aren't telling them the
truth
and by democrats they also mean
apparently the public health community
now it's also funny
to watch the other reporters try to keep
straight faces
when peter ducey is doing this it's hard
to imagine anybody's taking him
seriously in that press briefing room
but they do a good job at pretending
anyway
later just the cherry on top peter ducey
also framing
a question about a rise in crime under
joe biden of course the rise in crime
started last
summer under trump much of it crimes of
economic circumstance as a result of the
pandemic
and good job gensake actually points it
out on the rise in violent crime
i compared to this time last year
homicides up 113
minneapolis up 38 in philly up 22
in chicago just to clarify the white
house's position on this
is that that is mostly because of guns
well first i'm not sure what data you're
looking at but i think what we can
most data that is out there shows that
there's actually been a rise in crime
over the course of the last year since
the start of the pandemic which
actually predates president biden taking
office to be totally clear
right now you're right you're right
you're right peter and that's why we're
we are
focused well we're focused on uh
solutions here and that's why we
proposed uh putting a fight we put five
billion dollars in the american jobs
plan
okay so she gets into reading the
statistics which is fine
but just desperate to create chaos and
controversy and it feels
sort of wasted because there really are
good questions that peter ducey could be
asking if he wants to be
tough on the press briefing uh uh the
the uh press secretary and the the
process of of press briefing and taking
it seriously
but instead it's just this drivel time
and time again now i will say one thing
about
jen saki's handling of this her handling
of it is generally good
and sometimes you see like she was
better prepared for that
when you get the same questions every
day you get multiple attempts she was
better prepared
for the covet origins question on
tuesday than she was on monday
but she has to be careful because part
of asking the same
question day in and day out could maybe
be to create an inconsistency where she
says one thing one day and another thing
the next
materially different things or maybe
even a slip up of some kind
which peter ducey and then fox news and
the whole right-wing media apparatus can
focus in on in season and make like a
24-hour story out of it or
even a bigger scandal or pseudo scandal
so
clearly she's tired of it clearly so are
we but she actually does need to stay on
point every time and take the
fully answer the question every time
that he asks these questions
even if it's the same question every day
because they're just looking for an
inconsistency from her
gensake apparently the sort of
kindergarten teacher that's needed
in the press briefing room at this point
in time now let me go
briefly back to the lab leak or the the
man-made theory of covid
um i don't know anyone
who wouldn't want to know if covid were
man-made i would want to know there's no
question about it
the other scenario is if covid were
naturally occurring
but then leaked from a lab
in which it was being studied i would
want to know
i just want the truth but before we have
evidence
it's not responsible to say it's
probably been made and it's not
responsible to say
that that possibility is being covered
up and that's what the focus is right
now
either the left doesn't want to talk
about it you should see don junior's uh
recent tweets about this or there's
an actual cover-up of the fact that this
was probably likely
realistically a man-made virus there's
just no evidence of that
study the origins dr fauci said it i've
said it all along
study the origins let's not make
assertions for which we do not have
evidence
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
in a chewable form and at a fraction of
the cost
and they're giving my audience an entire
month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost
of confidence when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package
no driving around to the doctor's office
or the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made
in the usa the entire process is just a
few clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire
month's supply for free when you use the
promo code pacman
all you have to do is pay five dollars
shipping